i think the world of the division
is a world where
everything has changed everything's
being transformed
and
the normal rules of society don't
necessarily
apply
so it's asking the question of what
would you do
if no one was looking what would you do
if
not only your life but other people's
lives depended on it
so
the division agent for me has always
been
a representation of the people who go
towards trouble so
the division two continues that with
civilians and civilians settlements
being
one of the focuses for you to
invest
and protect
and that's very important for me these
civilian settlements when you first
arrive they're going to be in a terrible
state
and it's only through your actions and
helping the civilians organize
themselves that they'll upgrade and be a
reflection of
your actions within the world so there's
a real one-to-one
impact of your
efforts in the world within this happens
when we sat down and said you're going
to make a sequel to the division one one
of the
key points was was to make the open
world experience
more varied and more engaging which
means
making sure that there's surprises in
there for the player that you can't
predict everything that there's dynamic
life
and conflict in the world there are some
things that we were super passionate
about that we wanted to push
that were a main focus for the division
too for example our endgame first
focus and that led to
specializations and end game
plus
even the raids that we talked about but
e3 improvements of landing features has
been student set of focus from
from day one so we're looking at
everything from you the player where
specialization is really that well at
the start of end game there's more
progression for me to be had that it
sits alongside the gear game of finding
you know new gear and weapons and loot
in the world i get to actually evolve
myself as a character and i'm doing this
in a lot of new activities
uh of course replaying
the main missions
with certain twists that we not gonna
disclose fully yet but it's going to be
super exciting and of course the raid so
it's really about
creating
a tapestry of activity alongside
really fresh new things to do with your
character i usually say don't think of
specializations like classes because
classes is often
you know a choice you make
before you even
started the game you don't know what
what what will there be for me to enjoy
playing this class versus this class and
what would the game be like in any
detail
we're putting a specialization choice at
the end of the campaign you have played
through
you know a full campaign and a full
level journey of growing both
the variety of play style opportunities
for yourself but also the power and then
we're saying hey
now that you know all this how are you
gonna make a specialization choice that
sits on top of this it doesn't exclude
anything on the first game we had
certain challenges but on the second
game what
we felt the most pressure with at least
from my point of view
is
managing
the division one live at the same time
as doing conception for the division two
juggling those two things at the same
time
has been the hardest thing i've done
professionally
i love the dark zone for that atypical
pve
pvp experience and and you know that is
it that is the the question the moral
question of what would you do if nobody
is looking
so even if you are a division agent how
strong is your greed for somebody else's
equipment when you see that yellow back
so i love asking that question and how
to say i've never gone rogue
intentionally i think the the design
philosophy for the mission has always
been to grow opportunity to make choices
within that opportunity but have a lot
of flexibility
in changing if you play alone with your
friends you can do something really
tough versus exploring in terms of
inspiration at least my perspective is
what we wanted to do is add
more progression more options
in the end game
so again endgame focus first focus
where we go okay
you've done your progression
you've come to the end of the campaign
now we want to
make you invest in different types of
specializations that we're front loading
with the signature weapon so something
that you know symbolizes the journey
that you can take within that
progression but there's nothing stopping
you from saying i want to try out this
one now i want to be a survivalist now i
want to play with the crossbow now
yeah i would definitely have a
long-range ultimate rifle
and
probably
a shotgun already so
for me it's long range and soft imagine
a world
that's being completely transformed
by a killer virus that's been left loose
imagine
having the tools the equipment and the
skills to be able to save not just
washington dc
but the whole of the us
that's your mission i think we're ready
three two one go go go go
you